Leonardo would write about different topics,...
...how rivers flowed or the symmetry of wings.
You know, flight really fascinated him.
He always wanted to build some artificial flying machine.
He understood things that other people didn't figure out for hundreds of years.
So, he wrote all of his observations in these notebooks.
And all these notebooks, thank God they weren't thrown away.
Some were lost, but a lot are preserved to this day...
...including a small one that I own...
...called the Leicester Codex, which means notebook.
The rest are in European museums.
This idea of visualizing things and being able to draw it out...
...and then talk about the phenomena, that's in all of these notebooks.
And so they're unbelievable contributions to science.
Da Vinci, his whole life was most satisfied by scribbling and trying things out.
If you study things, a lot of things make sense.
Whenever da Vinci would get stuck, he had almost no peers.
In science, he was largely on his own...
...whereas now cool explanations of things are easily at hand.
So it's a great time to go forward with curiosity.
Walter talks about, "Hey, his human mind is not of a different character than yours."
Therefore you know, "Have fun with your curiosity."